you were shooting I think your first
really big movie which was sent of a
woman I was Yahoo the great Al Pacino
working together and is this right you
worked with Donald Trump on that film I
did I did now prep now president Donald
Trump with the president I say it's yes
yeah no we got new pages given to us one
day when we were filming at the Plaza
Hotel which I guess Trump owned at the
time and it said we were doing a scene
with Donald Trump and we were explained
to us that in order for us to film at
the Plaza we we had a little walk-on
part for Donald's action Marla is that
true that if the only way he would give
permission I don't know if he was in the
movie I wasn't making the deal and I'm
not sure how it worked but no I'll tell
you how it worked what do you mean I
don't know how it worked
I won't shy away from this he said yeah
they can shoot at the plaza if they put
me in the freaking movie what was
amazing it was amazing was he went
through the hole he came through her
hair and makeup and he ate on the set
but he looked the same going into hair
and makeup as he did when he left so
wait what part did they give him I don't
remember us and out of the movie yeah
yeah sure Donald yeah yeah we'll let you
in and they never had any yeah
so wait was it a scene that you knew all
along was going to get covered no words
it was we pulled up in a limo and Pacino
and I left and then another car pulled
up and it was Donald Trump and Marla
maples walked out and went in and right
cut and that was it right and Donald was
like probably thought that's gonna be in
the movie and they were throwing that
footage away as he was leaving I don't
know I like how you're playing it like
I'm not really sure I you're just so
afraid of being audited right now
I wonder how many time hurts doesn't it
anytime I wonder how many times he their
movies were shot at the Plaza and he
said you got to put me in it and they
had him come out of a limo and then he
went to the movie theater I just
pictured him going to countless movies
at the plazas in with popcorn here it
comes and then where is it former
co-star former co-star very nice
you